if you love reality TV shows as much as
we do Dance Moms is probably at the top
of your list
this series is jam-packed with drama
gossip and the occasional cat fights
watch until the end to find out which
crazy moment had us all glued to our TV
screens now let's jump right into some
of the craziest moments from Dance Moms
you need to see Kelly gets scolded by
Abby again it's no secret that Kelly and
Abby don't get along but there are times
when these two women take things a
little too far
season two episode 15 brought on another
classic Kelly
Abby fight but this time Paige got in
the middle when Abby asks her dancers
parents to do something she expects it
to get done ASAP so when she realized
that Kelly hadn't brought rubber
stoppers for her daughter's routine
things got a little out of control
although Abby didn't throw the chair
directly add Paige she did act in a
violent manner her actions put everyone
on edge causing Kelly to feel the heat
rising in her cheeks so she did what we
expected her to do
after Abby and Kelly spat pages routine
got dismissed causing her to storm out
of the studio with tears running down
her face
although Abby might look like a monster
here Paige could have gotten hurt if
she'd practiced her routine on a chair
that didn't have any rubber stoppers so
who's the real villain here Cathy's
revenge by now we all know that Cathy
who loves to disturb the peace which is
why she often finds herself in the
middle of a fight in season 3 episode 7
we're reminded that Cathy will go to
extreme lengths to get the last word
after barging into the back room Cathy
angrily approached Abby and it was clear
that she was looking for a fight well a
fight is what she got throwing water on
Cathy brought a smile to Abby's lips in
fact many of the other moms in the room
couldn't help but laugh out loud but
none of them expected Cathy to get her
revenge by swinging her purse into
Abby's face if there's one thing we can
always expect from Dance Moms its drama
so we weren't surprised when Jill came
to Abby's defense by the end of this
fight Cathy and Jill are drenched in
water and telling each other to grow up
now if that isn't hilarious we don't
know what is Christi goes rogue if
there's one dance mom who doesn't know
how to keep her voice down it's Christi
so when she had a bone to pick with Abby
and Melissa she chose to do it in front
of the entire studio this crazy moment
startled nearly everyone in the room but
hey we weren't expecting Christi to keep
her cool for too long instead of calmly
approaching Abby and Melissa with her
concerns Christi went ballistic causing
some of the kids to burst into tears
by the end of the episode it becomes
clear that Christi might have had a
little bit too much to drink this was
made obvious by the fact that there was
an empty wine bottle laughed at her
station
so there you have it guys another insane
Dance Moms moment this ordeal happened
in season 1 episode 4 proving that
things are only going to get uglier from
here on out minister dawn fights back
pain for dance lessons is expensive
especially when your daughter is being
taught by the notorious Abby Lee Miller
but if there's one thing every dance mom
should know before signing their
daughter up it's that they better come
to class in the right attire in season 1
episode 1 Minister Dawn's daughter Regan
got kicked out of acro class for wearing
socks in a t-shirt instead of taking it
as a lesson Minister done lost her
marbles after interrupting Abby's class
and frightening the children Minister
dawn was urged to leave however she
didn't take too well to being kicked out
instead of leaving the studio with her
daughter
the minister chased Abby around while
screaming at the top of her lungs so we
weren't shocked when Abby chose to call
the cops
while she might be a minister she sure
doesn't act like one
but we'd be lying if we said that she
wasn't entertaining a snake and a snake
Dance Moms is a dramatic reality TV show
that keeps most of us on our toes while
we're used to moms picking on moms we're
still not used to a be throwing shade at
nine-year-old girls even though it
happens in every episode it's painfully
obvious that Abby favors Maddie above
all her students and she doesn't try to
hide it so when Abby starts praising
Maddie's performance in front of
everyone else
Christy loses her cool
[Music]
before we know what's going on Abby and
Christi are in a full-on verbal fight
Christy gets accusing Abby of bringing
her students down and not encouraging
them when the fight starts to escalate
Melissa asurs Maddie out of the room
before she can burst into tears instead
of apologizing for putting Maddie on a
pedestal and leaving her other dancers
in the dark
Abby goes on to insult Christy's
daughter by the end of season two's
tenth episode
Chloe is in tears and tensions are at an
all-time high
Cathy and Christi are added again Cathy
and Christi have been at it since the
very beginning these two Dance Moms hate
each other with a passion and they make
it known in season 2 episode 3 Cathy
insults Christi and basically starts a
fight for no reason and this is how it
all begins after finding out that Cathy
throughout her bee costume without
consulting her first Abby starts fuming
and Christi steps in
this is between Abby and I for long Abby
is long forgotten and Christi and Cathy
are each other's throats again but
instead of fighting behind closed doors
both parents embarrass each other in
front of the entire studio the fight
nearly turns physical when Cathy starts
pushing and shoving Christi out of her
face these two moms have some issues to
sort out but it's clear that it isn't
going to happen anytime soon
Jill vs. Cathy we love drama which is
why we can't help but laugh whenever
Cathy starts acting up in season five
episode 18 Cathy's anger gets the best
of her once again causing her to fight
with both Abby and Jill after
confronting Abby and telling her to shut
her mouth
both women start yelling at each other
so loudly that it's hard to make out
exactly what they're saying both ladies
are having trouble containing their
anger which causes the other Dance Moms
to roll their eyes in annoyance Jill and
Cathy spite escalates quickly causing
bouncers to separate them but by the end
of this scene it's unclear whether or
not Jill's going to get her phone back
the engagement ring Fiasco gossiping is
to dance moms like chips are to salsa
they get the party started so when the
other moms noticed that Melissa isn't
wearing her engagement ring they start
poking around for the details
but unfortunately for them Melissa isn't
about to give them any ammo instead of
talking about her relationship issues
Melissa gets annoyed by their comments
and storms off to collect her daughters
seriously in season 2 episode 11 we see
how far Melissa will go to run away from
her feelings instead of telling the
other moms that she doesn't want to talk
about it she storms off making her
daughter cry in the process luckily for
Maddie Addie is ready to bite the bullet
for her to make it to the weekend show
despite being super angry
Melissa ends up doing the right thing by
letting her daughter compete the
look-at-me fight in season 3 episode 18
The Dance Moms head to New York for a
competition while watching their girls
rehearse an argument breaks out between
the two Christie's and it gets ugly
quick after going on and on about how
she would never let her daughter go ice
skate
two days before a dance competition
Christi Chloe's mom ends up rolling her
eyes of one too many times knows she's
not gonna skate
two days before competition before long
Asia's mom's emotions get the best of
her and she starts yelling at Christi
with all her might at this point it's
obvious that Asia's mom feels insulted
and wants the other dance mom to stop
making faces at her and insults start
getting thrown around the other moms
began to shift uncomfortably and can you
blame them after all a physical fight is
about to break loose so which Christi
would you put your money on Hollies
claws come out it's safe to say that
Holly is the most reasonable dance mom
out there she's not one to get into
pointless fights and tends to stay away
from foul language
however in season five episode 6 we see
a side of Holly that we never thought
would surface when Abby misses a whole
week of practice and then punishes her
dancers for not being prepared
Holly strikes back Holly's trying to
find out why Abby penalized her daughter
and no one else and she won't stop until
she gets her answer by the end of this
fight it's clear that holly is fed up
with everyone in the room she walks out
and scolds all the other mothers in the
group and for once we got to see dr.
Holly out of her element Kira's got
issues tensions are at an all-time high
when Kira and the mini moms start
bumping heads in season 6 episode 6 we
see Kira turn red with anger when she
starts to lashing out at Abby's mini mom
team the elite moms and the mini moms
face off in an epic battle one that ends
with Kira getting physically violent
by now all Kira wants is for the
intruders to get out of the studio but
they're not going anywhere the many moms
add fuel to the fire by staying cool
calm and collected causing Kira to go
berserk
although Kira tends to be a more mellow
mom she isn't one to avoid drama
altogether so knowing this were not
surprised that she shoved two other moms
when her words and insults weren't
landing this mommy meltdown episode is
loaded with hectic scenes many of which
are using with drama street fight if
there's one thing every Dance Moms fan
knows all too well is that Christi has a
little drinking problem more often than
not Christi goes into arguments or
fights whenever she's under the
influence in season 3 episode 37 the
Dance Moms go to New Orleans for a
competition and choose to grab some
drinks together which proves to be a
huge mistake
before long Christi is starting to roll
her eyes and cause drama and it doesn't
go unnoticed to say that Leslie is
annoyed by Christy's behavior would be
an understatement which is why these
events eventually take place it takes
Christi all but one second to throw the
first hit which clearly takes Leslie by
surprise the two women go for each
other's throats but get separated before
anyone gets hurt all in all it's obvious
that Leslie was right Christi did have
too much to drink
Kira pulls a fast one is it just us or
does every episode of Dance Moms get
crazier and crazier in season six we got
to see Kira's true colors when she lost
her cool in episode 12 after finding out
the Melissa struggled to take care of
her daughter for 12 weeks
Kira gets offended in her eyes Melissa
should have told her she was struggling
instead of acting like everything was
okay and bad-mouthing her to everyone
else
she did swatch your kid for 12 weeks and
you called her a horrible person finding
out that Melissa was two-faced about the
entire operation angered Kira to the
core so much so that she and Jojo see
you as mom
jessalyn started to bump heads you're
attacking and you're really not the most
brightest person in the room but you
would think that convinced that Justin
was in the wrong
Kira chose to act violently towards her
this resulted in Kira being left alone
by the other Dance Moms to contemplate
her actions
all in all Kira's got to learn to relax
because throwing stuff at people never
makes you the winner
Tami loses it emotions are at an
all-time high when Christy and her
daughter Sarah are welcomed back into
the elite competition team while Christy
might be here to make amends
Tami isn't about to let her off the hook
too easily Christy and Tami start
fighting right off the bat and within
seconds things get a little out of
control when Christy throws a reciept at
Tammy the mom goes crazy and bulldozes
over everyone in her path to get to
Christy determined to attack Christy
with all her might Tammy ends up getting
held back by a bouncer before she can do
much damage however it's clear that
Tammy means business and she won't stop
until she gets a few hits in by the end
of this episode Tami and Christy are
looking for blood in the water and they
won't stop until someone gets sent home
this crazy Dance Moms moment is
definitely a show stopper Kelly's last
straw we're about to reveal the craziest
Dance Moms moment so get ready to catch
your jaw before it hits the floor
in season 4 episode 7 we saw a side to
Kelly that we never knew existed
her actions that day resulted in her
getting kicked off the show and brought
to court
although Abby isn't totally innocent
when it comes to this fight she's not
the one who got violent first so she
ended up calling the cops on Kelly and
not the other way around let's take a
look at how the fight got started in the
first place once your mother quit
speaking for you you're 15 years old
grow you know what you shut the hell up
a be pushed Kelly's buttons when she
made jabs at her while talk
to her daughter this caused Kelly to
turn into the Hulk and trust us when we
say that it wasn't pretty
after putting her face where it didn't
belong Ivy got attacked by Kelly who is
obviously provoked although it's obvious
that Kelly's got some issues
that doesn't make Abby an angel in the
end this little spat caused Kelly and
her daughters to get booted off the show
and the whole thing got taken to court
so who's your favorite dance mom and why
let us know in the comments below and
that's the end of our video thanks for
watching and see you next time
on two things
[Music]